first on eight plans are being made for
the land that used to be the home of the
Fiesta Rancho and Texas Station
documents filed with the north Las Vegas
Planning Commission show a plan to
redevelop it into a mixed commercial
residential area called Hilo Park
featuring office space Hotel restaurants
a sports field and multi-family housing
both casinos were demolished over the
last year with the only the fiesta ice
skating rink in a parking garage
remaining a new ice rink will also be
part of Hilo station or Hilo Park rather
the plan needs FAA approval since it is
adjacent to the north Las Vegas Airport
the north Las Vegas city council will
discuss it at their next meeting on
Wednesday